[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to once again
be discussing the upcoming fantastic
beasts film fantastic beasts 3 the
secrets of dumbledore however today
we're not just going to be discussing
release dates filming locations and
prospective actors we're going to be
discussing the title of the film and its
significance
early in our childhoods well at least
for me and a lot of you we were first
introduced to dumbledore the lovable
hogwarts headmaster and at that stage
his life was still very much a mystery
there he was a powerful and respected
wizard that presided over the youth of
the magical world but what were his
formative years like how did he become
the man that people came to love and
respect expanding on this further was
dumbledore actually a good person or was
he sort of gray like snape and just more
personable luckily thanks to the
fantastic beast films which are
effectively harry potter prequels we're
finally getting a closer look at
dumbledore's formative years the time
that shaped him into the man that he is
today your youth is the perfect time to
make mistakes because it gives you an
opportunity to correct them as you
progress through the rest of your life
we've had two fantastic beasts filmed so
far fantastic beasts and where to find
them as well as fantastic beasts the
crimes of grindelwald those two came out
in 2016 and 2018 respectively so we've
been without harry potter content for a
while however fortunately the third
fantastic beast installment is going to
be hitting theaters relatively soon on
april 15th during easter of 2022 along
with the release date being announced
the film's much weighted title was
released as well with film creators
landing on fantastic beasts the secrets
of dumbledore now with a title like this
you're practically begging for harry
potter fans to speculate dumbledore has
a dubious past there's no doubt about
that but what secret is this title
referring to today i want to discuss
some theories that i have regarding the
meaning of the film's title now as it
happens dumbledore's past is so
controversial that at one point it
prompted rita skeeter known journalist
to publish a biography on the beloved
hogwarts headmaster entitled the life
and lies of albus dumbledore skeeter's
poison piece ran a staggering 900 pages
in length and was published four weeks
after dumbledore's death in june 1997.
given that the book was published after
dumbledore's death it's unclear which
segments of the book were genuinely true
and which parts were fabricated by rita
as dumbledore was not around to protest
despite the book's success and five-star
rating from the daily prophet the book
was met with mixed reviews from those
who were close to or knew dumbledore
personally
ron's aunt muriel for example praised
the book while those such as ilfius doge
were furious at skeeter's attempts to
tarnish dumbledore's good reputation the
timing of the publication the book was
also in particularly bad taste as she
intentionally used dumbledore's death as
a launch pad the book dove into
dumbledore's humble beginnings
particularly focusing on his family life
and relationship with grindelwald
while i'm sure some of the information
in the book was a product of rita's
uncanny ability to write libel there is
evidence to suggest that a good deal of
information was accurate the reason for
this is that while gathering info for
the book skeeter interviewed bethilda
bagshot grindelwald's great aunt while
under the influence of veritas serum
bagshot knew dumbledore and grindelwald
well so as far as sources go she is very
credible after the book was published
skeeter sent a copy to bagshot with the
following note dear batty thanks for
your help here's a copy of the book hope
you like it you said everything even if
you don't remember it rita what an awful
woman anyway with all that said let's
jump into my top three theories for what
will be revealed as dumbledore's secrets
in the upcoming film albus dumbledore's
evil side now if you're privy to the
harry potter story and dumbledore's
character then you already know that
dumbledore had a bit of an evil or
misguided streak however the side of
dumbledore has yet to be shown on screen
in either the harry potter or fantastic
beasts films so maybe just maybe this is
the first time we'll see his former evil
intentions revealed gelat grindelwald
the primary antagonist in fantastic
beasts was born in the year 1883 and in
his younger years he was a student at
durmstrang institute while attending the
school grindelwald's sadistic nature
churned through and he was expelled for
experimenting with twisted and dark
magic when he left school grindelwald
traveled to godric's hollow where he met
a young albus dumbledore grindelwald had
just been expelled and was a bit lost
and dumbledore had been dealing with all
sorts of family issues from the moment
they met the two spent every minute
together and eventually began plotting
upon establishing the slogan for the
greater good it was their intention to
find the fabled deathly hallows then
lead a wizarding revolution that would
effectively put an end to the
international statute of secrecy
breaking down the secretive divide
between the two worlds this revolution
would create a global power hierarchy
that would place powerful witches and
wizards the top of the food chain
effectively giving them full control of
muggles and muggle affairs that's right
dumbledore at one stage wanted to rule
over muggles that's a dirty dark secret
if i've ever heard one the family
secrets now when you say dumbledore most
people will think of albus but what we
need to remember is that dumbledore is a
surname the film title may actually be
referring to the dumbledore family and
not just albus as an individual and when
it comes to the dumbledore family as a
whole there are certainly a lot of juicy
tidbits we could be exposed to and that
pretty much applies to every family
member dumbledore's mother kendra
dumbledore was the wife of percival
dumbledore and the mother of albus
ariana and aberforth dumbledore she was
a muggle-born witch with jet black hair
dark eyes high cheekbones and a straight
nose not much is known about kendra but
we do know that she died in an explosion
when her 14 year old daughter ariana
lost control of her magical abilities in
fact the only person who had anything to
say about kendra was ron's aunt muriel
who expressed that she was a terrifying
woman who was ashamed by her squib
daughter locking her in a cellar but
muriel isn't exactly credible so who
knows percival dumbledore was a pure
blood wizard husband to kendra and
father to amber forth ariana and albus
when percival's daughter and albus's
sister mariana was six she was brutally
assaulted by three muggle boys the
incident left ariana with an inability
to control her magical abilities when
percival found out about what had
happened to his daughter he furiously
attacked the three muggle boys for this
he was sentenced to azkaban percival
never explained the reason for attacking
the mughals to the ministry as he feared
that if they knew of her condition she
would be locked away in saint mongo's
hospital due to her existence being a
hazard to the statute of secrecy this
led to much speculation about percival's
crime and many believed that the attack
was driven by a radicalized perspective
on blood purity which couldn't have been
further from the truth after being
locked away in azkaban eventually died
in the prison maybe his sister being
attacked was what began driving albus to
his evil side credence at the end of the
last film we were left on a pretty big
cliffhanger as one of the last things we
witness is grindelwald revealing to
credence barebone that he is in fact a
member of the dumbledore family albus's
long lost brother aurelius dumbledore
though grindelwald doesn't confirm who
exactly aurelius's parents are since he
refers to albus as a young man's brother
we can safely assume that he belongs to
at least one of albus's parents before
this point in time it was widely thought
that there were only three dumbledore
children albus aberforth and ariana in
order for credence to carry the
dumbledore name it would mean that he
would have had to have come from
percival's side as kendra's maiden name
is kanaat did percival have an affair
with another woman maybe soon we'll find
out and that's it for this video what do
you think the secrets mentioned in the
title refer to comment down below also
if you enjoy the content please consider
liking the video and subscribing to the
channel until next time remember it does
not do to drill on dreams forget to live
[Music]
you